hello everyone my name is dr. Baker I'm
filling in for dr. Miller still don't
know what's going on but today we're
gonna be looking at something kind of
funny in my opinion anyway SCP 49 J
object class Hughley miss if that
matters special containment procedures
SCP 49 J is contained at site 19 Sci 101
site 17 site 81 site 13 clearly the
person who wrote this couldn't make up
their mind anyway special restricted
high-security top-secret MK ULTRA area
region landmass 101.5 WF ml near
Richmond VA SCP 49 J is permitted to
leave its holding cell only under
supervision of two armed guards with
ar-15 assault rifles and stun batons due
to all factory concerns for staff signed
to SCP 49 J the entity is no longer
allowed to remove its masks description
SCP 49 j is a humanoid entity wearing
the period appropriate garb of a
medieval plague dr. further analysis of
SCP 49 J has revealed that under its
robes the entity is composed mostly of
moss lots of tissue and other smaller
plague doctor masks but is generally
compliant with foundation staff but will
sometimes lie and occasionally sweat
profusely for no reason whatsoever
during SCP 49 days time and foundation
custody
it has continually claimed to be a
powerful magic dr. wizard capable of
quote curing unquote at which quote ails
mankind unquote to date
it has been unable to cure literally
anything and typically only exacerbates
conditions considerably while this alone
would not be enough for the foundation
to hold SCP 49 J indefinitely as an
anomalous entity it is also proven
capable of somehow always evading
capture and escaping from foundation
sites after its true lack of
capabilities are revealed because of
this and because of staff's unwavering
curiosity as to whether it has any of
the self-proclaimed magical healing
abilities it describes a SCP 49 J is to
be housed and treated as an anomalous
entity addendum 49 J 0.1 this is an
audio interview which I'm going to play
now
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
yes he has a sore throat we were
wondering if you know of any keywords to
fix the Ritalin yes of course need any
help over there yes that's a shoe yeah
that will heal this person what the [ __ ]
was that
hey zoom what
no no she's not you crushed her Grover
the shoe no this is very well look at
all this squad morale atrocities aside
this is going to take hours to clean up
you just killed a person no they are
curious watch
hello yes I am the special cook sir I am
cool mercy thank you thank you doctor
you did a good job you will the best
doctor now look here I see your hands
down there I know that isn't the patient
talk what is this supposed to be what
he's gone again
god damn it
post-incident video logs show scp-1498
making a brisk escape through a side
door additional footage gathered from
the nearby town gels SCP 49 j sopping in
a hardware store to pick up quote
pointer wooden doctor stick well there
you have it man working in the
foundation has its perks sometimes does
dr. Jade know about this if he doesn't
know someone's gonna have to tell him
anyway
class dismissed go do whatever
you
[Music]